[Musique]
pendant toute la durée du vol aller à la
vôtre à l'abattre s'ils chantent
et donc j'ai encore est en fait baby
chanteur alors fait j'avais ce cas là
des deux côtés et encore mais d'enfer
fait je crois que j'ai jamais été
amoureux n'avaient pas encore retrouvé
mon poids j'ai en plus j'ai grandi
sérieux ce que je fais tout ce que je
crois que je fais rien disons juste
contre nous les choses dans sa phase
postérieure
je fonctionne pas entre nous on peut
savoir ce qui se passe si jacques harper
arrive bonjour et bas bonjour monsieur
ensuite rappel je viens à bord de
l'avion celui sur qui tu as des versions
mobiles est le numéro un
la one tout ce que je vous ai dit tout
récemment ce que ça fait d'avoir repris
reste secret je me demandais si vous
voudriez ça vous dirait qu'on vit
ensemble numéro un le parent triste que
vous ressentez un et aurier avoir
n'importe quelle femme et ses beaux
cheveux vous êtes assez méfiant il est
plus que connor m'aidait pas il
s'intéresse à moi
ce qui est à confier les choses à propos
du nom
alors comme ça tu te fais sauter par
jaccar peuvent ranger vos affaires quoi
est-ce que vous renvoyez ggb multi
métiers de pavie qui fonctionnement que
des secrets sont plus importants
plaignants non c'est archi faux de dire
ça je t'assure je veux plus jamais
parler avec thor 2 mois août aux pentes
de susi
par exemple j'aurais dû partager bien
plus gâcher on devrait toujours tout se
dire lorsqu'on fait la rencontre de
quelqu'un
[Musique]
j'avais une circoncision